just a little bit just to hammer out
some facts on what's going on in cuba
um the cuban people are protesting like
crazy um
the main the main things that have
um at least they've probably come to us
in terms of their why they're protesting
has been lack of food um lack of access
to coveted vaccines or just like
mishandling of covet in general and then
there's now been i think the last final
straw was these blackouts or electricity
shortages
um and they
have gotten more access to the internet
in recent years
starting a little bit in 2014 and really
accelerating 2018
um historically we have always had an
embargo on cuba because we don't like
communism in the united states we don't
think it should exist
bad things happen um uh at least that's
been our stance on it so like since 1960
we've been
um putting embargo with trade we don't
allow trade to happen between cuba and
the united states
besides food and medicine and that's
fluctuated in a number of different ways
obama eased this in 2014
which is why he saw more internet access
in cuba and a little more tourism
and trump came in and revoked it said
absolutely not
and biden hasn't touched it yet and this
is an important thing
to focus on for a minute the obama
easing it because
something that i've heard and that makes
a lot of sense to me is
you had this hope start to to exist
in cuba when obama came in and eased the
restrictions and opened the way for
tourism and
and opened their economy you know or
helped their economy in that way
and what's happened over the last year
and a half two years three years four
years five years whatever it's been
was like a walk back of that hope and
there is a a very there's a pattern in
like international affairs where
revolutions start when things start to
get a little better and then get worse
again
it's not it's no no it's it's yeah it's
not just abject
poverty or abject misery it's when
people start to think things might get
better and then that gets pulled back
from them
that's when you start to see in many
ways what we're seeing which is for the
first time you have people in cuba
acknowledging that they're living under
a dictatorship for years they couldn't
even say that publicly
or they were too afraid to say that
publicly because it was taboo
and the other thing i want to point out
and then we can continue on with this
narrative is there's really three things
that have happened recently
you had trump
reimposing stricter sanctions embargoes
et cetera on the country
after obama you also have the collapse
of venezuela
and venezuela venezuela came in when we
when we were not giving them any
like traders well specifically venezuela
provided them with
heavily subsidized oil so they were
reliant on heavily subsidized oil from
venezuela and
and that sort of collapsed
and then you have covet obviously hit so
these three factors sort of all hit it
once
on top of existing struggles frankly
because of communism because you have 88
of the population working for the
government because you have essentially
planned economy because you don't have
private markets um and
that's been devastating yep and so i
love i'm
fascinated by this narrative because no
one's really talking about i don't think
we can actually say
for certain that this is a case but if
i'm a as a political strategist
this is where my head is at that obama's
like okay let's ease this up
let's help the cuban like the embargo
that the u.s has put on cuba is
hurting the people of cuba i mean like
it's less less money in the country
right um less less everything
um so obama eases it trump puts it back
theoretically biden could quickly
say hey we're going back to what we did
with the obama era i mean he could do
that right
um however the big and we mentioned this
earlier in this podcast
is the big factor no one's been talking
about is the reason biden lost florida
is because of cuban americans that do
not like living in miami and dade county
that do not like the cuban government
and
are in miami because they want to escape
from that
and by the way if like you look at
numbers
in florida they thought duval county
where jacksonville is
if they flip that blue they're going to
win because miami is always democratic
and miami did go democrat but it was
less it's usually like 80 20 i think it
was 60 40
dem republican um and that's massive and
if
there's i would say like if that keeps
shrinking there's no chance of winning
florida
for the dems realistically anytime soon
um so there's that pieces puzzled which
i think is fascinating in this narrative
and you've got biden coming out the
biden administration and his spokes
folks are coming out saying like
hey it's just that we're it's first
things first for us right now we're
focusing on covet recovery et cetera et
cetera so this is just not
a top priority for us right now that's
their talking point
for why they're not going back to
obama-era um
policies i think your take is obviously
very interesting
and you know there's been arguments that
that's why trump did what he did
was to i mean he made the announcement
about renewed sanctions
on cuba in miami-dade county like to a
group of cuban americans
um while he's hammering how socialist
the democrats are
um so it's it's i mean it's a tragic
situation i don't like the embargo i
don't think it's helpful i think it is
just hurting the people of cuba i think
we have a better shot of getting cuba to
call it i would say modernize i'm sure
that'll piss people off but
by by building these bridges to cuba
um which was what obama was trying to do
um
but there are clearly all sorts of
political considerations that
beyond just the cuban people i um i have
two
questions that i think i'd like to wrap
up this this topic on um
one i want to talk about the future of
the party in general and then i want to
talk about um how
we as consumers of media can like
navigate this because that's the goal of
this so let's start with the future of
the party
do you we kind of touched on this a bit
um
do you i think the pressure
i guess i'll start my opinion on this i
think the pressure from the dsa type
candidates is going to increase not
decrease because it's
um it's good news fodder it's good
material right where black lives matter
is coming out and saying we support
um the people of cuba but we also blame
the us government for doing this you
have
dsa saying something similar you end up
with like bernie and co
all like trying to thread this needle
but it keeps this like social
like we like socialism we don't like we
don't like all of it
um in the headlines and the republicans
will always keep adding fuel to this
fire because anytime they hear the word
socialism they're like oh yeah
this is how they win elections this is
their like just hammer it all day long
baby
so i think i think the republicans will
continue in elections by this because i
think the average american doesn't like
socialism
um but do you think that starts to shift
or like you think the dems are getting
more wins in here or like
the four candidates have happened you
might get to eight to ten in congress
but that they start to become the
exception not the rule where your
thoughts on where it codes
it depends on what they decide to focus
on if these candidates
keep their message about medicare for
all
and our current economic system is
unfair
without suggesting national yeah if they
keep it on
that i think you'll see a lot more
traction
i think where it gets muddied is you
have a lot of people who
who are in that vein also adopt a lot of
talking points
around identity race justice on that
stuff and whatever you think i mean
obviously
i'm actually in favor a lot of that but
i think the talking points around them
are often very unhelpful for winning
elections if you if you continue to see
that side of things really bleed into
the economic side of things i think
um i think you'll continue to have what
you have which is pockets of this
succeeding but in
by and large the country actually
reacting very much against it and going
the other direction
if you have candidates that are sticking
strictly to the economics of it which
was really burning
in 2016 that was more more his lane
um i think you could see more traction
in a way that
i actually support um
how about you i think um
and this is probably that probably
answer my second question too like how
we should consume this
um to me i think it's very the data is
very overwhelming
and historical anecdotes overwhelming
that socialism in the way is
traditionally defined
is bad it is a bad thing it's never
worked um
the way if you're if you're consuming me
the way that aoc and bernie and others
are talking about socialism they're not
they are using that term so that can be
scary but they're not fun like
theoretically they're not always talking
about
they're more talking about sweden in
norway denmark than they are talking
about
which means socializing certain
industries like healthcare
sidenote sweden for example has private
health insurance in addition to
public like i think the way
and i think what all of us as consumers
need to try and understand that um
when this term is thrown around on both
sides of the aisle there's different
definition that people are using and
it's important to try to understand what
they mean
but i think the real future is i think
india walton who's the woman who just
won the
democratic primary in buffalo for mayor
beating a at least two-term incumbent i
don't i love buffalo
go bills uh love you josh allen um but i
don't i don't live in buffalo i don't
claim to know enough about this race but
i do know it appears that she ran her
race not on
i'm a socialist uh these but she
but more on power to the people and that
people on the ground or closes these
issues can solve them
um and it was issue focused but from the
american um
like she's not calling for into
capitalism or in the free markets um but
more about
stopping people piling up at the bottom
this populist version of this
and i think that's the lane um because
capitalism has a ton of benefits but
people will pile up at the bottom and
it's the government's job to kind of
figure this out and level the playing
field um in its own way
and great policies can do that
[Music]
so
you